hola soy alan austria y les doy la
bienvenida a este especial de noticias
donde a partir de este momento y por las
próximas dos horas y media aquí en
france 24 vamos a llevarles toda la
información y el análisis de la segunda
jornada de la convención nacional
republicana que comenzó ayer y termina
este jueves para ello iremos en unos
momentos con nuestros corresponsales en
washington y los ángeles y además de que
tendremos numerosos invitados con
quienes analizaremos los discursos de
esta noche esta jornada lleva el tema
del ant of opportunity tierra de
oportunidades y se espera que se
destaquen los logros económicos y de
política exterior de trump y que se
toquen temas como el comercio el aborto
la migración y la crisis de opioides del
país veamos algunos de los oradores de
esta noche el secretario del estado mike
pompeo que se espera aborde el historial
de política exterior del presidente de
eeuu donald trump una inusual incursión
en la política interna del principal
diplomático de la nación también
hablarán los hijos de trump eric y
tiffany trump
así como su esposa para muchos el
discurso más esperado la primera dama
melania trump mayoría en mendoza también
hablar a una madre de cuyo hijo fue
asesinado por un migrante indocumentado
entre otros más
esta convención republicana al igual que
la demócrata la semana pasada se celebra
por primera vez en sus más de 150 años
de historia de manera virtual debido a
la pandemia del cob y 19 pero también
incluye algunos eventos presenciales la
primera convención se realizó en
pittsburgh el 22 y 23 de febrero de 1856
ayer en la primera jornada el presidente
de donald trump y el vicepresidente mike
pence fueron confirmados oficialmente
como la fórmula republicana a la
casablanca y la ex embajadora de eeuu
ante la onu nick reilly
defendió la política exterior de trump
mientras que su hijo donald trump júnior
calificó los planes de bailén como
socialista y de izquierda radical hoy ya
han dado sus discursos el senador rand
y el agente retirado del fbi richard
beasley entre otros más en un vídeo
pregrabado el presidente de donald trump
entregó el perdón presidencial a jon
anders es por ello precisamente que
empezamos debatiendo esta jornada
y creemos que cada persona está hecha
por dios por un propósito yo continuaré
dándole a todos los estadounidenses
incluyendo a los exreclusos la mejor
oportunidad para comenzar una nueva vida
y lograr su propio sueño americano se
dice que esta convención republicana de
2020 se ha estado preparando desde 2016
pues hace cuatro años fue muy criticada
con malestar entre algunos delegados
republicanos una programación descuidada
y un polémico discurso de la esposa de
donald trump melania trump que hoy va a
hablar lo decíamos y que hace cuatro
años fue muy desacreditada porque partes
de su discurso eran idénticos a los de
michelle obama ocho años antes esta vez
el equipo de trump con años para
prepararse busca una convención más
pulida a pesar de la pandemia del cob y
19 comenzamos las intervenciones con
nuestra corresponsal en washington
buenas noches por allá en la capital
diana castañeda que resalta del discurso
de trump
bueno básicamente veníamos de nuevo como
las apariciones que tiene sorpresa al
presidente yo una acción porque no hacen
parte del programa oficial pero el día
de ayer vimos en varias oportunidades
que aparecía en la convención hoy lo
hizo hablando con reclusos que estaban
digamos en las prisiones por penas muy
altas
digamos condenas muy fuertes por delitos
menores y que lograron este perdón
presidencial este ha sido uno de los
programas bandera del presidente donald
trump tratando de liberar a personas que
tenían digamos extensas condenas y que
quiere mostrar también que va como parte
de su programa de justicia racial que
tratan digamos es uno de los temas de
los republicanos para vender en esta
convención pero además de eso también el
presidente pues es el único momento en
el que vemos a ciudadanos hablando con
el mandatario y es algo completamente
diferente a lo que veíamos en la
convención demócrata donde
y grabaron más de mil vídeos con
anticipación de ciudadanos en diferentes
estados
hablando de sus preocupaciones y también
hablando de el programa de baile
hablábamos de el polémico discurso que
dio hace años la esposa de donald trump
melania trump y que en sí la convención
fue muy crítica a la convención
republicana entonces qué tan pulida
considerada esta esperada convención con
lo visto el día de ayer y lo que lleva
el día de hoy
bueno hemos visto que esta convención
republicana está más centrada en la
figura del presidente y los logros que
ha alcanzado el presidente de doral son
desde el punto de vista del partido
republicano más de de las propuestas que
tiene si llega a la casa blanca que
hasta el momento no han sido
desarrolladas a profundidad es algo
diferente a lo que vimos en la
convención demócrata donde el plan se
centraba en la recuperación de la
economía y de la nación después de la
pandemia este tema de la pandemia no ha
sido desarrollado ampliamente y es
entendible dentro de la convención
republicana debido a las múltiples
críticas hacia el presidente
donaldson porque eeuu encabeza la lista
de países con mayor número de casos pero
también no sólo está como mencionabas la
polémica del discurso que dará la
primera dama desde los jardines de la
casa blanca también el discurso que va a
dar pregrabado el secretario de estado
mal pompeo que ha generado
fuertes críticas por miembros del
congreso de los eeuu del partido
demócrata que incluso han hablado de
abrir una investigación en su contra y
esto debido a que graba este vídeo como
parte de un viaje oficial que está
realizando a israel violando los códigos
establecidos por el departamento de
estado que prohíbe a un oficial en
función de promocionar o trabajar
digamos en campañas políticas mientras
está utilizando fondos de las personas
que pagan impuestos a los
estadounidenses para financiar este
viaje así que de por sí ya este segundo
día de la convención comienza con esta
polémica y para finalizar este momento
contigo diana va a estar contigo durante
todo el especial que resalta de la
jornada de hoy que lleva por nombre
tierra de oportunidades porque
decidieron los republicanos darle este
tópico a la jornada de hoy
bueno estará centrado en el plan que
tiene el presidente de donantes en
materia de empleo la meta que tiene de
crear más de un millón de nuevos empleos
en 10 meses al igual que crear nuevas
pequeñas empresas estará centrado
también en el tema de inmigración y la
relación que hace el partido republicano
de cómo evitando la inmigración ilegal a
través de la frontera de méxico
habrán mayores oportunidades dejando
atrás el tema de construir un muro en la
frontera ya que durante su
administración pues no logró conseguir
los fondos fueron negados dos veces en
el congreso de los eeuu para construir
este muro así que ya no es la insignia
que vemos para está digamos segunda
campaña y otro de los temas en los
cuales continúa la segunda jornada como
mencionaba anteriormente es el de la
justicia racial pero la defensa también
del ejercicio que tienen los
departamentos de policía también veremos
reforzando estas
ideas principales a varios miembros de
la familia del presidente donald trump
que hablarán hoy no solamente la primera
dama sino también dos de sus hijos
muchas gracias diana castañeda vamos a
seguir contigo y este momento les
queremos recalcar la importancia del
voto duro que tiene donald trump pues
está llevando a movilizar el voto de sus
electores que son leales a las políticas
del presidente estadounidense les hemos
preparado este reportaje
bombero un dueño de restaurante un
granjero todos miembros del partido
republicano y todos dispuestos a votar
una vez más por donald trump porque
tomás buddy es el jefe de la estación de
bomberos en gastonia carolina del norte
y le gusta sobre todo el estilo de
presidente bueno tienes que ser un poco
rudo en la forma en que abordan las
cosas y como les dije para mí eso es lo
que necesitaba el país y sus bomberos
han estado al frente de la pandemia de
ccoo y 19 ya que a eeuu le ha ido
particularmente mal
trump podría haber hecho un mejor
trabajo dije no lo manejo lo mejor que
pudo para hacerlo cuando se trata de
kobe 19 no hay un manual
gastón ya es una antigua ciudad
industrial textil que ha luchado por
adaptarse a la economía global este
dueño del restaurante dice que el
historial de trump en la economía es
excelente
hoy hemos aumentado nuestras ventas en
un 20% cada año hemos proporcionado muy
buenos salarios a nuestro personal
nuestros huéspedes tienen más ingresos
disponibles para venir a disfrutar y
cenar prendiendo la economía anterior al
cob y es también a lo que estos votantes
strumpf buscan aferrarse él tiene el
mercado de valores en las mejores
alturas de su historia así que todos
tienen que estar felices todos nuestros
ahorros de sistema pensional se han
hundido durante tanto tiempo y ahora lo
estamos haciendo realmente bien de nuevo
para estos cristianos devotos trump ha
cumplido su palabra de defender sus
valores en particular sobre el aborto
fue el primer presidente de eeuu en
asistir al mitin pro-vida todos los
demás presidentes ya conoces a los
republicanos han dicho que eran pro-vida
pero cada vez que se presentaba esta
manifestación siempre decían oh estoy
ocupado el granjero edwin lindberg
reconoce que trump no ha construido el
muro que prometió en la frontera
mexicana pero dice que no es culpa del
presidente
trump lo intento en mi opinión y además
fue bloqueado en todos los sentidos por
los medios de comunicación y por los
liberales
pero todos estos votantes están de
acuerdo en un punto
donald trump estaría mejor si publicara
menos en las redes sociales
empezamos hablando con nuestros
especialistas primero la republicana
ella es marili cancio estratega
republicana y asesora de latinos por
trump muchas gracias por estar con
nosotros señora canción trump dice que
joe biden es una amenaza de socialismo e
izquierda radical que acercaría el
escenario estadounidense al de venezuela
está de acuerdo con esta tesis del
presidente estadounidense todo el
partido republicano no sólo es cosa de
trump
no eso no es cosa de trump ni del
partido republicano eso es cosa del
partido demócrata vimos como bailén se
ha acercado la ala izquierdista del
partido demócrata con el propio
socialista senador bernie sanders siendo
uno de los principales que nombró a byd
en oficialmente en la convención
demócrata teniendo al extraño caso
cortesía bernie sanders como los líderes
de verdad del partido demócrata que son
personas socialistas con ideas
completamente radicales y eso es lo que
vamos a ver en una presidencia de
marketing muy bien muchas gracias marili
cancio vamos a estar constantemente con
usted y con nuestros especialistas
aprovecho ahorita que vamos arrancando
para pedirles una disculpa a todos los
involucrados porque los voy a estar
interrumpiendo acorde a los
pronunciamientos que se esperan en la
convención republicana ya les
mencionábamos varias figuras destacadas
del partido republicano de la del
gobierno de donald trump y de la familia
de donald trump hablará en el día de hoy
vamos ahora con daisy vice ella es
estratega demócrata
aquí le agradezco también que esté con
nosotros es también ex representante
estatal de la florida por el partido
demócrata estados unidos sigue siendo la
tierra de oportunidades como lo
identifica por ejemplo hoy la temática
de este día de la convención republicana
ciertamente que lo es el país que ha
progresado y se ha convertido en la
nación poderosa que es por la fibra que
tenemos de todos los inmigrantes que
venimos a este país que venimos a
contribuir que trabajamos duro que
venimos a mejorar la calidad de vida de
nuestras familias también en las últimas
dos años
[Música]
si te interrumpo porque estamos teniendo
algunos problemas de comunicación vamos
a estar checando de que te escuchamos
mejor por lo que no te doy la despedida
vamos a seguir contigo por supuesto y
nos vamos con diego área él es un
experto en política exterior
radicado también en washington dc muchas
gracias por estar con nosotros señor
área los oradores fueron el centro de
atención el día de ayer o pasaron
desapercibidos porque tenían el mismo
discurso divisivo de todos contra
el comunismo orden primero comunismo al
último o cuáles consideras que fueron
los momentos más memorables de la
primera noche
bueno primero que todo muchas gracias y
sin duda alguna ayer la convención el
primer día de la convención republicana
se centró más en en los temas en los que
ya desde la campaña de 2016 donald trump
ha posicionado en la narrativa política
la narrativa de la contienda política
que son contrastar el contraste
ideológico conectar a los adversarios
del partido demócrata con la perspectiva
socialista pero pero además hemos podido
ver un intento de acercamiento de
seducción a estas poblaciones
minoritarias afrodescendientes y latinas
con la aparición del senador de carolina
del sur team scot de nicky reilly
tratando de hacer apología a la cercanía
de tumbalá a la humanidad de tron como
líder cercano a estas minorías pero
además siempre haciendo un enfoque muy
importante sobre su capacidad para
manejar la economía del país sobre todo
posterior a la pandemia que ha afectado
tan duro el bolsillo no solamente de los
norteamericanos sino del mundo entero
pienso que el día de ayer no fue un día
de grandes personalidades fue un gran un
día de grandes temas
hoy veremos como personalidades como el
secretario de estado punto y melania
trump harán aparición y darán
seguramente mucho de que hablar bien
diego área muchas gracias experto en
política exterior en eeuu seguiremos
contigo nos falta escuchar todavía a
mauricio cárdenas corresponsal de france
24 en los ángeles
mauricio te saludo nuevamente qué gusto
que estés con nosotros te advierto es
muy posible que te interrumpa en
cualquier momento habla abby johnson
ella pues es activista en el tema de los
derechos contra el aborto pero primero
toquemos temas que están día tras día en
esta convención republicana estamos a
dos meses y medio de esas elecciones
pero las encuestas favorecen claramente
al candidato demócrata hace cuatro años
también favorecían a la candidata
demócrata como podemos entender esta
noticia
te lo advertí mauricio disculpa le vamos
a escuchar a billones solo si volvemos
contigo
volvemos contigo ahorita una activista
provida cuando estaba en la universidad
la pareja se aproximó a mí y hablaron de
ayudar a las mujeres en crisis y su
compromiso de mantener el aborto seguro
legal y escaso yo estaba convencida de
ser voluntaria y de ofrecer y me
ofrecieron un trabajo como asistente
médica antes de mi promoción a la
directora de la clínica realmente creí
que estaba ayudando a las mujeres pero
las cosas cambiaron drásticamente en el
año 2009 en abril me dieron el premio de
empleada del año y me llevaron a su gala
donde presentaron el mar
el premio margaret sanger en nombre de
su fundadora era una racista que pensaba
en la agencia pti y pensaba que había
que erradicar las poblaciones
minoritarias hoy cerca del 80% de las
instalaciones de este evento están
estratégicamente ubicadas
en barrios de minorías y cada año se
celebra sus raíces racistas presentando
el premio margaret sanger en agosto ni
supervisor me dio una nueva cuota que
cumplir una cuota de abortos
se suponía que debía duplicar la
cantidad de abortos y el año cuando me
di cuenta que iba en contra de lo que me
han dicho que haría me dijeron que las
abortos es la manera como ganamos dinero
pero el punto de inflexión cambió cuando
un médico me llevó a asistir una
ultrasonido
para un aborto nada me preparó para lo
que pude ver en esa pantalla y un bebé
luchando de manera desesperada para
alejarse de la succión y nunca me
olvidaré de lo que me dijo el doctor
después mía pescar y está conmigo scary
lo último que vi fue su espina dorsal
moviéndose antes de hacer sucumbir a la
fuerza de la succión el 6 de octubre me
fui de la clínica es por eso que ahora
soy una activista pro-vida
una organización que ha ayudado a cerca
de 600 trabajadores fuera de su
industria las personas que se consideran
pro-vida
el aborto es algo abstracto ni siquiera
pueden concebir la barbarie
de lo que ocurre ahí donde los cuerpos
de los niños
los van a unir para
se hacían bromas diciendo que eran los
cuartos de la sal
[Música]
como se ve sea que huele saben que el
aborto incluso tiene un olor ácido la
perpetradora de estos actos con bebés y
camps con las mujeres y ahora apoyo
acción porque la ha hecho mucho más por
los bebés no nacidos que ningún otro
presidente durante su primer mes
prohibió el financiamiento para los
grupos que promovían el aborto y ese
mismo año cambió una regla de la era de
obama que permite a los subsidios para
el aborto
whitesides y llevó a jueces incluyendo
dos jueces de la corte suprema y anunció
una nueva regla protegiendo los derechos
de los trabajadores de salud que se
oponen al aborto muchos de los cuales
con los que trabajo ahora todos los días
la vida es un punto central de lo que
somos como estadounidenses y esta
elección es una elección entre mundos
activistas y activistas anti vida y el
presidente más pro vida que hayamos
tenido y eso es algo que debería
convencerlos y llevarlos a la acción
en puerta a puerta llamen hablen con sus
vecinos y con sus amigos y voten el 3 de
noviembre y tomen acción que lleve para
la reelección y para proteger a los más
vulnerables a aquellos que no han nacido
aún
escuchamos a abby johnson activistas de
los derechos contra el aborto quien
ejemplificó su situación de como este
tema es sensible para ella ella que es
conferencista escritora y activista
pro-vida dice que tras abortar dos veces
y trabajar para una multinacional y en
el que ejercía como directora de una
clínica renunció en octubre de 2009
después de ver un aborto por ultrasonido
ultrasonido ella lo dijo pues mucho más
emocional ampliando mucho más el tema
ella dice que esa empresa buscaba sobre
todo los objetivos financieros y
duplicar la cantidad de abortos posible
regreso contigo mauricio cárdenas para
que concluyan la idea anterior que tanto
podemos creer ahora en las encuestas
pero también ya vamos abordando este
tema del aborto que es pues uno de los
puntos principales en los que difieren
tanto republicanos como demócratas es
más los invitados de trump dicen que byd
en apoye el aborto hasta el momento del
nacimiento que tan radical consideras
esta posición de joe biden
frente al aborto te escuchamos
es una posición bastante complicada para
un político en este momento aquí en los
eeuu donde la polarización se ha vuelto
más común y más frecuente en todos los
temas en el tema del racismo en el tema
del aborto en el tema de inmigración y
en ese caso pues en california que es un
estado mauricio disculpa mera disculpa
de mauricio bailén obviamente hay
millones
mauricio te voy a interrumpir nuevamente
estamos escuchando ahora a nicolás sanz
man él es estudiante que demandó a los
medios de comunicación tras enfrentarse
a una activista indígena lo escuchamos
de ponerme esa gorra
me haría el blanco de los medios a nivel
nacional siendo de kentucky el lugar
donde nació link con mis compañeros y yo
visitamos el memorial a lincoln
me encontré cara a cara con nate en
philips y con otros manifestantes
profesionales que querían hacerme ver
como el último póster de mostrar porque
trump es algo malo los medios no
mostraron como un agresor
con una sonrisa de superioridad en mi
cara y el vídeo simplemente muestra que
yo estaba parado ahí con las manos
detrás de la espalda y la sonrisa quería
decir dos cosas uno no hagas nada que
pueda agitar al hombre que está
golpeando el tambor enfrente y dos
estaba siguiendo el consejo de mi
familia mis amigos nunca hagas nada para
avergonzar a tu familia a tu comunidad
oa tu escuela antes de saberlo ya se
había acabado
el señor a phillips
lo tenemos ya todo está en vídeo
y ganamos lo que pensé era que ese
extraño encuentro se desarrolló en una
gran historia para los medios y para las
noticias y mi vida cambió para siempre
la máquina de los medios y comenzaron a
atacarme
lo hicieron sin mirar todo el vídeo del
incidente sin investigar los motivos del
señor phillips y sin preguntarme a mí
cuál era mi punto de vista y saben por
qué
porque la verdad no era importante
avanzar con su agenda anti conservadora
anticristiana y su narrativa anti dólar
era lo único que importaba y avanzar con
eso significaba acabar con la reputación
de un muchacho de kentucky pues que así
fuera eso le enseñara a no ponerse una
gorra
de donald trump no sabía que eso tenía
un hombre se llamaba cancelación
la cancelación es lo que le estaba
ocurriendo a la gente en este país a
aquellos que no quieren ser silenciados
por la izquierda radical muchos han sido
humillados e incluso amenazados y a
veces los medios son partícipes de esto
pero a mí no me van a cancelar yo luché
para exponer los medios por lo que me
hicieron a mí y tuve una victoria
personal aunque mucho más debe hacerse
espero y que llegue el día que los
remedios entreguen información
balanceada y responsable sé que el
presidente trump espera eso también dice
que ustedes están de acuerdo cuando
decimos que nadie en este país ha sido
una víctima de un recubrimiento injusto
más que un 8 de noviembre creo que este
país debe unirse alrededor del
presidente
se rehúsa a permitir que los medios
creen narrativas en lugar de reportar
los hechos creo que debemos unirnos al
presidente que va a retar los medios
para que vuelven al periodismo objetivo
y juntos creo que todos debemos recibir
y apoyar los derechos de la primera
enmienda ni de los medios ni de las
muchedumbres y esto es algo que por lo
que vale votar y luchar y esto es lo que
donald trump defiende gracias a todos
por escucharme esta noche y una cosa más
que hagamos a eeuu grande de nuevo
[Música]
escuchamos a nicolás and man el
estudiante que demandó a los medios de
comunicación tras enfrentarse a una
activista indígena cómo fue este suceso
el 18 de enero de 2019 tuvo lugar un
enfrentamiento ampliamente reportado
entre grupos de manifestantes políticos
cerca del lincoln memorial en washington
dc la interacción entre el adolescente
nicolás santana quien acabamos de
escuchar y el activista nativo americano
night and phillips fue capturada en
fotos y videos los informes de ese
incidente provocaron indignación en eeuu
después de que muchas historias
mostraran a los estudiantes católicos
como los agresores los estudiantes
recibieron incluso amenazas de muerte y
su escuela en por gilles que en toki
cerró temporalmente debido al temor por
la seguridad de los estudiantes los
vídeos cortos del encuentro recibieron
millones de visitas al principio la ira
se centraba en los estudiantes y en la
escuela pero a medida que se publicaban
más vídeos del incidente
opiniones sobre lo que realmente había
sucedido polarizaron la opinión
estadounidense el incidente fue descrito
como una convergencia explosiva
raza religión y creencias ideológicas
ese es nicolás and man que concluyó
bueno antes de decir hagamos nuevamente
américa grande de nuevo eeuu dice que
nadie en este país ha sido más víctima
de los medios de comunicación como
donald trump me informaban que vamos con
quién
vamos nuevamente con mauricio cárdenas
mauricio discúlpame que te he estado
interrumpiendo un par de veces les decía
a todos los invitados tenemos a mauricio
me dicen que mauricio cárdenas hemos
perdido la comunicación pero entonces
regreso con nuestra estratega
republicana marili cancio muchas gracias
por continuar con nosotros marilyn
hablemos precisamente de estos temas
pues tan polémicos y que marcan mucho la
agenda de donald trump una es el
activismo contra el aborto y el otro es
como los medios de comunicación pues han
afectado al presidente estadounidense
bueno yo creo que han habido estudios
que demuestran que la cobertura del
presidente en su mayoría son negativas
más de un 90 por ciento de todo que se
acabe de presidente es algo negativo
hasta este muchacho los en mente de la
forma que se presentó él nos va a ir
activando a nadie le estaba ahí en parte
de esa escuela y por tener ese sombrero
y gorra puesta lo acusan de estar ante
visualizando las personas
acá te dejamos la vida este pobre un
tacho me dan gusto saber qué cortes
americanas y diezma justicia y él por lo
menos pudo ganar en corte contra alguno
de los medios pero si vemos el tema de
aborto es algo que deben hacer que hay
una gran diferencia entre el partido
demócrata y el partido republicano igual
que el tema de armas el tema de
impuestos
puede [__] renovar para sus hijos
tenemos el partido de la libertad es el
partido republicano en el himno muy bien
muchas gracias marili canciu vámonos
ahora con daisy vice la estratega
demócrata y seguir con el tema del
aborto mira la corte suprema de eeuu
daisy pues rechazó el 21 de junio una
ley del estado de luisiana que
restringía el aborto esto pues un revés
para donald trump cuyo gobierno pues
apoya fuertemente esta norma como ésta
el capital político de los republicanos
y cómo analizás en sí toda la estrategia
legislativa de los republicanos en torno
al aborto
la realidad es que los republicanos han
tratado numerosas veces de eliminar
reducir o poner difícil el acceso de las
mujeres americanas a servicios
reproductivos no estamos en pro del
aborto estamos de que la decisión de una
mujer es personal entre ella y su médico
y a una vez atrás de la otra las cortes
siempre han vuelto al mismo tema que es
el derecho a la privacidad que es un
derecho que da la constitución y que
cuando los estados y los republicanos
lanzan este tipo de leyes siempre acaban
entorpeciendo pse y volviendo para atrás
porque saben que la suprema corte no los
va a sancionar así que esto lo vamos a
ver repetidamente una vez y otra vez es
parte del asunto estamos viendo lo que
es el festival del trompo esta semana y
este es su oportunidad como la tuvimos
nosotros la semana pasada
de presentar nuestros temas nuestras
ideas y esto lo está venciendo y esta
semana están enfocándose en algunos de
estos temas porque lo que el presidente
no puede hacer es defender el récord que
tenemos ahora mismo de 177 mil muertos
una póliza fallida y de cómo lidiar con
la crisis del cob y 19 una economía en
piqué de millones de personas
desempleadas fue una pérdidas
millonarias de trabajos así que como no
pueden defender este récord fallido el
presidente con pocas victorias
legislativas estamos enfocando nuestros
temas que son unos temas muy divisorios
daisy ya nos mencionaba mauricio
cárdenas que según los invitados por la
convención republicana dicen que yo va a
ir en el candidato demócrata apoya el
aborto hasta el momento del nacimiento
que tan radical es la postura respecto a
este tema del candidato presidencial
demócrata
esto obviamente no es cierto el
candidato demócrata no apoya el aborto
hasta el último día el candidato
demócrata
como ya dije apoya el hecho de que las
personas las mujeres tengan una
discusión con su médico y tomen
decisiones de salud personalmente esto
es como muchas personas personas hoy en
día dicen que no se quieren poner las
máscaras en mí es mi decisión personal
eso es algo no es tan sencillo como eso
pero es el derecho de una mujer de
evaluar su salud y en tico y con digamos
evaluar los métodos anticonceptivos que
están disponibles para ella legalmente y
eso es la posición del presidente el
candidato a presidente ennio by den
muchas gracias decisiva es en lo que
solucionamos unos problemas de
comunicación con los otros invitados
regreso contigo marili cancio estratega
republicana alguna respuesta de lo
pronunciado por la estratega demócrata y
también te quiero añadir que trump dijo
que no disminuirá el impulso a sus
políticas sobre el aborto
esto lo dijo el día de hoy como se puede
traducir esta postura en votos es
arriesgado puede que si bien le sume
pero otros que le pierda fuertemente el
apoyo de aquellas personas que no
comparten sus ideologías
yo creo que proteger la vida siempre es
una buena idea mantener la palabra de
que la vida es lo más importante y
proteger la vida de un bebé que aún no
ha nacido la oscura del partido
demócrata es promover leyes que permitan
que un bebé que
será un aborto fallido que más el bebé
que trataron de aportar que después que
en la que ese bebé que pueden terminar
con esta vida es algo insólito de que se
puedan pensar que pueden mataran a un
niño después de nacido estas son las
políticas del partido demócrata no es
una decisión de la mujer y su médico es
una decisión de quitarle la vida a un
recién nacido
tenemos llega te digo que personalmente
tengo una niña una nieta que cumple 13
años esta semana y pudiera haber sido
víctima de un aborto porque sus padres
en esa época tenía 18 19 años y gracias
a mis convicciones en la de nuestra
familia de ser prohibida esa niña nació
los cumplir 13 años y tengan hellen
lossi tres vidas pero es muy fácil en la
sociedad decir incómodo no no vamos a
tener a este bebé necesitamos personas
que quieran promover la vida para que no
nos vivimos una cultura de monte es
hacer
una vida porque no es algo cómodo para
nuestra sociedad que las mujeres tengan
el derecho a tener en pastilla cortitas
de que quieran venir a un embarazo y no
desean eso está bien pero tenemos que
proteger la vida de los bebés que están
perdidos porque quien más baja de esas
vidas nosotros somos el partido pro vida
y tenemos que luchar por esas vidas
indefensas son las personas más
vulnerables en nuestra sociedad si fuera
por los demócratas
y bueno vamos a eliminar este bebé que
no no se quería que esa mujer quizás no
quiera hay tantas personas que están
dispuestos a adoptar niños es una pena
que
los demócratas creen que cualquier bien
desechable muy bien muchas gracias
vamos a continuar contigo miley cancio
pero ahora pasado nuevamente con la
estratega demócrata daisy vice daisy
trump dijo ayer nuestro país nunca será
un país socialista y el público
respondió con gritos de aleluya y de say
you say en eeuu no que ha sido muy
popular la idea de una distribución de
ingreso equitativa o al menos
completamente equitativa como
reaccionarán ante este tema los
demócratas
la realidad es que tú tienes toda la
razón no es un país socialista un país
capitalista es un país de oportunidades
estamos completamente
vamos a escuchar ahora a tiffany trump
la hija del presidente en la comisión
hace cuatro años tantas cosas han
cambiado en el mundo para nuestro país y
para mi familia
como tantos estudiantes alrededor del
mundo yo me gradué de la escuela de
leyes durante la pandemia nuestra
generación está unida se enfrentando el
futuro en momentos inciertos y muchos de
nosotros estamos considerando qué tipo
de país queremos vivir
como una recién graduada puedo verme
reflejada en muchos de ustedes mi padre
creó una gran economía una vez y lo hará
de nuevo créanme
por eso les pido a cada uno y les urjo a
ir más allá de las barreras políticas
esta es una lucha por la libertad en
contra de la opresión por la oportunidad
en contra de la estagnación una lucha
por mantener a eeuu
verdadera a sí misma
hagamos un juicio en redes pasados
resultados si creen en la reforma la
justicia penal solamente hay un
presidente que pasó el lef forster act
dándole a la gente una segunda
oportunidad en la vida una oportunidad
en la vida nuevamente y si creen en
expandir la salud asequible solamente el
presente champions mi padre firmó otra
acción para reducir los pesos de los
medicamentos y evitar que roben los
estadounidenses la gente debe reconocer
que nuestros pensamientos nuestras
opiniones e incluso la elección de por
quién estamos votando están siendo
manipuladas y lo están haciendo por los
medios y los gigantes de la tecnología
si van a los medios en una sola opinión
parcializada y si lo que crees no
concuerda con la agenda que ellos tienen
entonces se ignora o se dice que es una
mentira esta manipulación
de la información que recibimos impide
nuestra libertad en lugar de permitir a
los estadounidenses formar sus propias
creencias esto mantiene a la gente
mentalmente esclavizada y esto es un
miedo y una división que no son
necesarias porque tanto en los medios en
el mundo de la tecnología e incluso
nuestro gobierno están tan comprometidos
con promover una visión parcializada a
las cosas pregúntenselo porque porque no
nos dejan ver cierta información porque
solamente se promueve un punto de vista
mientras se esconden los demás la
respuesta es control porque la división
y la controversia crean beneficios pero
cuáles son las consecuencias cuando
solamente un lado de la historia sale o
cuando solamente un punto de vista se
convierte en aceptable para nuestro
sistema educativo significa sacrificar
el debate civil creando una atmósfera de
los estudiantes con opiniones contrarias
no pueden hablar
y tratan de encajar y nuestra nación
sufre acabando con la diversidad de
pensamiento y la inclusión de ideas
trabajando por fuera de nuestra zona de
confort política va a cumplir mucho más
y algunos son políticos cínicos no
quieren creer en el milagro de eeuu pero
yo sí como máxima predijo la noche si se
pierde la libertad en este país no hay
ningún otro lugar a donde ir tener
esperanza no es una debilidad y creer en
los milagros es un regalo de dios
entonces esta noche quiero decirles la
verdad de en qué creemos nosotros
creemos en la equidad de la oportunidad
nosotros creemos en la libertad de
pensamiento y de expresión piensen lo
que quieran busquen la verdad aprendan
de otros con otras opiniones y hagan su
voz escuchada en el mundo
creemos en la elección de escuelas
porque el lugar donde vivía un niño no
debe determinar su futuro creemos en la
libertad de religión para todas las fes
y creemos en el espíritu estadounidense
un país fundado en ideas no en
identidades donde nuestras diferencias
son aceptadas y donde la palabra sueño
es válida porque aquí
tu vida es tuya si estás escuchando esto
y estás pensando ese es el tipo de país
en el que quiere vivir bueno ya sea que
te hayas dado cuenta o no estás apoyando
a hecho quiero que veas más allá de la
fachada de los políticos si se hacen
pasar por decentes mientras tratan de
acabar con nuestras identidades y
creencias mi padre es la única persona
que ha retado al establecimiento así a
la burocracia interna al mono de los
monopolios de los medios y a las
farmacéuticas
para asegurarse que las verdades
constitucionales se mantengan y él no la
escapa un reto incluso ante el odio
porque luchar por eeuu es algo por lo
cual él va a sacrificar cualquier cosa
que él sueña en grande para este país y
tira con todo para alcanzarlo entonces
eeuu grande de nuevo no es un eslogan
para mi padre es lo que lo impulsa para
mantener su promesa de hacer lo correcto
para los ciudadanos estadounidenses
la energía del cambio y la oportunidad
está con nosotros dios nos ha bendecido
con un espíritu que no se puede parar el
espíritu estadounidense mi padre ha
probado de estar impulsado por ese
espíritu él ha demostrado su fe y en su
corazón y también con sus acciones mi
padre me ha hecho creer que estados
unidos realmente puede ser grande de
nuevo si te importa vivir tu vida sin
restricciones
sin tener que rebelarse contra aquellos
que tratan de oprimir la entonces la
elección es clara un voto por mi padre
es un voto para mantener y defender
nuestros ideales estadounidenses y
mantenernos verdaderos a estas
realidades estadounidenses muchas
gracias y que dios los bendiga
y stephen y trump la hija de donald
trump quien hace una aparición pública
poco común no es muy habitual verla
pronunciándose en los medios de
comunicación a diferencia de sus
hermanos mayores
tiffany ha desempeñado un papel más
discreto en la administración trump que
lo que hablo sobre todo lucha por la
libertad contra la opresión
también dijo que trump buscará evitar
que le roben a los estadounidenses e
hizo énfasis principalmente en los
medios de comunicación bueno ahora
escuchamos a kim reynolds y es
gobernadora de agua y agua es un gran
estado ayudar a los vecinos está en
nuestro adn
desde el campesino que tiene necesidades
hasta la madre que pierde su empleo y
que tiene también dificultades la
comunidad nos ayuda a salir adelante
pero qué ocurre cuando pasa una tormenta
porque destruye todo el estado cuando no
es un campesino el que ha perdido su
cultivo sino cientos cuando no eres un
vecino en problemas sino que suena
miles los que no tienen comida eso es un
huracán paso
con vientos fuertes y acabó con tres
enteros de tierra dejó a miles sin
electricidad y destruyó hogares y dejó
devastación en su paso fue la peor
tormenta en la historia del estado y lo
que que hicieron las personas de iowa
fue lo que esperaron se cuidaron unos a
otros y aún lo hacen pero alguien más
nos apoyó nuestro presidente cuando los
vientos habían pasado él apareció tal
vez no puedan saberlo porque los medios
no lo reportaron pero la administración
ya estuvo aquí con toda su fuerza
después de la tormenta el presidente
llamó para asegurarme que teníamos todo
el apoyo del gobierno federal y más
adelante esta semana el vicepresidente
pensó vino agua para de nuevo
asegurarnos que el presidente y su
administración estaban con nosotros con
la ayuda de la administración son
rápidamente recibimos una declaración de
desastre qué
nos ayudará a ponernos de pie nuevamente
el presidente acabó con la burocracia
para que se hiciera lo que tenía que
hacerse de manera rápida pero esa no es
la primera vez que el presidente camps
le mostró a la gente de iowa que
podíamos contar con él en 2019 cuando
las inundaciones devastaron las
comunidades tanto grandes como pequeñas
a lo largo del río missouri en iowa
nebraska missouri el presidente aprobó
nuestra petición de ayuda en un tiempo
récord en dos días bueno este año lo
hizo en menos de 24 horas así que ya se
ha dado el alivio para los campesinos
que fueron víctimas de las prácticas de
china o creando nuevos tratos
comerciales o apoyando las víctimas del
cobi 19 tenemos a un presidente y un
vicepresidente que hacen lo que hay que
hacer y es por el presidente camps y por
su liderazgo que nuestro país ahora
puede volver
crecer la oportunidad ésta es una
administración de acción y de resultados
que están cumpliendo todos los días en
su promesa de hacer eeuu grande
nuevamente y eso es exactamente por qué
tenemos que reelegir al presidente
donald trump en noviembre gracias y que
dios bendiga a los eeuu de américa
ella es quien brain nose la gobernadora
de iowa quien identificó la ayuda que ha
dado el gobierno del presidente de
donald trump a su estado era uno de los
discursos más esperados pues esta
gobernadora la primera mujer en ocupar
este puesto en iowa
es conocida como una de sus fortalezas
las relaciones internacionales que tiene
con diversos países tres de ellos
latinoamericanos por ejemplo méxico
argentina y brasil tiene
un gobierno que usa mucho el comercio
internacional en temas de agricultura y
de fábricas no solo con estos países
latinoamericanos por supuesto con china
canadá israel tailandia vietnam
filipinas alemania y lo mencionamos
brasil argentina y méxico son los que
más se identifican vamos a ver qué opina
nuestra corresponsal en washington diana
castañeda que tenemos vía telefónica en
lo que retomamos comunicación con
nosotros invitados
diana que impresiones te deja al momento
el pronunciamiento de la gobernadora de
iowa con reynolds pero también de la
hija de donald trump tiffany trump quien
hace cuatro años también había
pronunciado un discurso que puede bien
recibido
si lo que estamos viendo es como
discurso tras discurso se está
reforzando los valores tradicionales del
partido republicano y el especial
énfasis valores que el presidente don
acción que le da la importancia como
políticas
es para proteger la vida antiaborto
costillas refuerzan una y otra vez la
narrativa de restar credibilidad a los
medios de comunicación de los medios de
comunicación brindar una visión parcial
para tener control como lo decía en su
discurso
tiffany sonrisa del presidente y como
hemos visto también de otras bebidas
importantes del partido republicano el
día de ayer y el día de hoy que a
diferencia de lo que vimos en la
convención demócrata eran más los
testimonios de los ciudadanos en el país
que hablaban de las políticas demócratas
y de lo que se esperaba para el 252 si
llegaba bailén a la presidencia y lo que
ahora veremos se espera que sea el
siguiente participante de esta
convención
el secretario de estado de los eeuu
maison pero quien hablara del segundo
punto más importante de esta noche que
es el liderazgo de eeuu en materia de
política exterior donde el presidente
trata de llevar este mensaje en esta
convención de algunos de los nombres
pero también retos que tendrá que
enfrentar
enviamos el manejo que ha dado a las
relaciones con china durante esta tensa
relación de guerra comercial de mutuas
sanciones sobre la monda lucha por el
respeto al derecho de propiedad
intelectual en los eeuu y que se ha
deteriorado aún más después de la
pandemia y de que el presidente haya
utilizado calificativos como el virus
chino también es posible que hagan
referencia al retiro de las tropas de
afganistán a la relación con corea del
norte y por supuesto uno de los temas
centrales que lo vimos ayer y que lo
veremos importante del secretario de
estado es la relación y el liderazgo que
ha tenido el presidente o nación frente
la política exterior con israel no sólo
por el reconocimiento de jerusalén como
capital de israel también por este
digamos viaje que está teniendo ahora el
secretario que ha sido tan polémico para
tratar de lograr que otros países árabes
apoyen este liderazgo de de israel y
también
digamos un perdido en común no sólo para
los países árabes en la región sino como
lo considera la casa blanca a nivel
global el riesgo que implica
irán así que te dan algunos besos tengan
los que aborde el secretario de estado
en pocos minutos cuando comience a su
discurso diana correctamente nos estás
identificando como los temas
prioritarios para muchos republicanos el
día de hoy el manejo en política
exterior por parte del gobierno del
presidente de donald trump también como
nos señala mike pompeo hablará en
cualquier momento en la convención
republicana se espera que toque diversos
temas sobre todo aquellos relacionados a
israel que ya nos estás identificando
estos dos precisamente estos dos
discursos el de la gona hora de iowa
quin reynolds y el de mike pompeo quien
es responsable de la diplomacia
estadounidenses son los momentos más
esperados por los latinoamericanos pues
son los que podrían hablar de la crisis
de venezuela de la frontera con méxico o
de algo que atañe a los latinos
están pendientes hoy de esta convención
republicana
lamentó diana te escuchamos
perdimos a diana castañeda pero puedo
retomar en este momento a mauricio
cárdenas él es corresponsal en los
ángeles y él ya nos estaba identificando
pues los temas del día si las encuestas
son engañosas contigo me quedé en ese
tema mauricio cárdenas pero también si
tienes algún comentario a lo que se ha
pronunciado hasta el momento en la
convención republicana por ejemplo el
pronunciamiento de la hija de trump se
esperaba que nuevamente mostrara
aspectos familiares otra faceta de
donald trump una faceta de padre pero no
fue así y no ha sido así con los
pronunciamientos de los hijos en esta
convención republicana de 2020 te
escuchamos mauricio
yo creo que aquí hemos visto una muy
polarizada convención demócrata y
también estamos viendo con la convicción
republicana
por eso los temas que él mismo se le
sorprendió ver a la joven del famoso
este de la gorra
lo cambiaron que está y que fue también
utilizado para llevar su mensaje esta
convención y de la hija del show de
titanic
hablando más que el tema familiar sino
de la desinformación al igual que lo
hizo el hijo mayor del presidente el día
anterior entonces estamos viendo que es
tocar los temas palpitantes que han sido
la constante durante esta administración
que pretende reelegirse y que pues al
parecer no tiene un camino fácil porque
esa radicalización ha llevado a que los
dos bandos se separen cada vez más y más
y volviendo al tema que tú mencionabas
pues las encuestas dan favorito a vaivén
pero si miramos un poco hacia atrás
vemos que aquí la ligera
antia favorita para ganarle al
desconocido en temas políticos donalson
y ya vimos lo que pasó entonces creo que
hay las encuestas y los pronósticos hay
que tomarnos con fin
porque realmente no sabemos si voy a dar
la sorpresa o si finalmente los
demócratas logran ponerse de acuerdo
para hacer una 1000 de una campaña y
lograr sacar a este presidente de la
casa blanca' creo que se nos avecina un
3 de noviembre increíble del pronóstico
reservado y como para alquilar balcón al
año
tiffany trump nos mencionaba como bien
nos identificas mauricio cárdenas que
pues la batalla que está enfrentando el
gobierno del presidente de donald trump
es contra los medios de comunicación e
hizo énfasis también en esta era digital
que también tú ya nos estás trayendo al
tema y es que es cierto estamos en una
era de hiper conectividad en la que se
puede llegar a una ciudad ciudadanía por
otras vías y que hoy es muy activa en
redes sociales es hiper conectada es muy
consciente como harán tanto los
republicanos como los demócratas para
llegar a esta difícil audiencia
perdimos a mauricio castañeda mauricio
cárdenas perdón nuevamente les ofrezco
una disculpa le recuerdo estamos
totalmente en vivo transmitiendo la
segunda noche de la convención nacional
republicana ahora vamos nuevamente con
diana castañeda nuestra corresponsal en
washington diana te dirijo la pregunta
que le habíamos hecho a mauricio
cárdenas estamos en una época de
digitalización que viene identificaba en
su discurso la hija de donald trump
tiffany trump que ahora con esta
sociedad pues la batalla no solo es con
los medios de comunicación tradicionales
sino también con esta nueva era
si los dos partidos se enfrentan un reto
muy grande y es que estas elecciones
históricamente se dan en medio de una
pandemia y se van a dar también el 3 de
noviembre cuando según las autoridades
en materia de salud de los eeuu se
podría dar una segunda ola de contagios
debido al invierno así que es uno de los
temas más difíciles de manejar en la
seguridad a la hora de asistir a los
centros de votación y es algo que el
partido republicano ha aprovechado ya
que el presidente ha encabezado algo que
consideran los demócratas como una
campaña de desprestigio del sistema de
correos de los eeuu que ha llevado
también advertencias por parte de
fiscales en diferentes estados como la
fiscal general de nueva york que
asegurando que si el presidente intenta
detener las elecciones de extender la
fecha de votación e incluso de cortar
ese derecho a voto a través de correo
puedes enfrentar a acción
es legales y ese digamos que es uno de
los problemas de confianza que tendrían
que enfrentar los demócratas para que la
gente efectivamente vote de manera
anticipada a través de correo y que se
puedan garantizar también las medidas de
seguridad cuando las personas acudan a
votar en persona el día de las
elecciones pero aparte de eso también
los demócratas se enfrentan otro reto
que es ver si esa unidad que mostraron
en la convención la semana pasada se
verá reflejada en las urnas que fue algo
que no ocurrió en las elecciones pasadas
a pesar del apoyo que dio sanders a
hillary clinton muchos de los jóvenes y
de seguidores de sanders no apoyaron al
candidato a la candidata en este caso
oficial ahora digamos en esta convención
sanders de nuevo hablado con vaivén lo
ha respaldado y los demócratas esperan
que esto se traduzca en las urnas y por
supuesto el gran reto también para los
republicanos
y la pandemia y el manejo que ha dado al
presidente donald trump en un país que
se encuentra en una profunda crisis
económica con más de 40 millones de
personas desempleadas solicitando
subsidios en donde los padres no saben
si enviar o no a sus hijos a las
escuelas si estarán a salvo y es un
debate que ha creado tensión entre los
gobiernos estatales y el gobierno
federal y también en donde aún no existe
un plan organizado y un plan
estructurado para lograr que más
personas puedan acceder a estas pruebas
para el coronavirus y tratamiento y sin
tener que recibir
digamos extensas cuentas de cobro por ir
al hospital lo que vuelve a abrir
también el debate del acceso a salud así
que es digamos una coyuntura muy
particular y sin precedentes en las que
se están dando estas campañas y estas
elecciones en los eeuu
bien bien a castilla ideas sigo contigo
ahora que te tenemos nuevamente en vídeo
pero es que en este momento ya son las
20 59 horas a bogotá ciudad de mexico
quito y lima es momento de darles una
actualización de noticias a esta hora en
france 24 veamos algunas de las noticias
avanzar la segunda jornada de la
convención nacional republicana
escuchábamos los discursos que marcan la
campaña del partido republicano a billón
son una activista contra el aborto y
nicolás sanz man un estudiante que
demandó a los medios de comunicación
después de una confrontación con una
activista nativo americano el aborto y
la discriminación racial es uno de los
temas principales en esta convención
republicana que tiene lugar mientras hay
protestas en wisconsin por otro presunto
caso de abuso policial contra un
afroamericano
tras dejar 10 muertos en haití y
república dominicana y de provocar daños
en cuba la tormenta tropical aura se
convirtió en un huracán de categoría 1 y
tocaría tierra en luisiana y texas el
miércoles la misma zona donde acabó este
lunes marcó que fue huracán pero que
perdió fuerza en su recorrido
el capitán del barcelona lionel mesi
habría comunicado de manera formal al
club su deseo de abandonar el equipo el
6 veces ganador del balón de oro el
argentino solicita que se le conceda la
carta de libertad para así poder firmar
por otro club
regresamos entonces con nuestra
corresponsal en washington diana
castañeda diana tu ya nos estabas
haciendo énfasis en algunos temas que
están siendo pues divisivos que es el
pulso que tienen ahorita los
republicanos y demócratas yo te
identifico otro el de la economía si
esto le puede jugar a favor o en contra
de los republicanos porque si bien
muchos economistas señalan que la
economía en eeuu estaba en auge antes de
que llegara el coronavirus se podría
pensar en que la continuidad es la mejor
fórmula para hacer frente a una crisis
económica
si lo que estamos viendo es digamos un
discurso completamente diferente por
parte de los dos de los dos partidos en
la convención demócrata ballén hablaba
de un plan agresivo de recuperación
económica y desde parte del partido
republicano de una continuación de una
continuidad pero lo que pasa es que la
economía está en un estado que ha
generado digamos una profunda crisis
debido a la pandemia y por ejemplo el
encargado de la reserva federal aseguró
que salir de esta crisis va a tardar por
lo menos un año más así que las
consecuencias están todavía en pleno y
se están viviendo no solamente por el
deseo del desempleo que se está viviendo
también porque hay en industrias muy
tradicionales de la economía
estadounidense que han sufrido
claramente el impacto como es el
petróleo como son las empresas
automotrices como son las aerolíneas
y esto pues ha generado desconfianza y
un poco de reserva por parte de los
ciudadanos frente a gastar dinero frente
a lo que será el 2021 y oportunidades de
empleo que se podrán generar y esto
también puede afectar a la campaña del
presidente de una acción porque digamos
que uno de los sectores que más había
intentado incentivar con promesas de de
restauración de empleo será precisamente
la industria automotriz a esto también
se le suma que hay muchas personas que
en los eeuu actualmente están esperando
más alivio por parte del gobierno
federal y que debido a las discusiones
entre demócratas y republicanos al
interior del congreso no han podido
recibir este segundo alivio que
esperaban y el debate sobre cómo no
o han podido recibir muchas minorías
afroamericanos latinos ayudas del
gobierno federal y sobre todo
inmigrantes que al no tener un estatus
legal más de 12 millones de personas en
los eeuu no pueden recibir ayuda federal
en medio de una pandemia así que esta
relación entre los efectos de la
pandemia y la economía claramente no
juegan a favor del presidente
donald trump y sobre todo porque hay
mucha gente que ha criticado el tono que
ha utilizado el presidente cuando en una
entrevista se le preguntó por la gran
cantidad de personas que han perdido la
vida en los eeuu debido a la pandemia y
él aseguró en una frase que es lo que es
y eso también fue una frase central que
vimos como parte de la convención
demócrata muy bien diana castañeda
aprovecho que tengo ahora a daisy vice
estratega demócrata y ex representante
de florida por el partido demócrata por
supuesto y también aprovechando que ahí
vemos en pantalla que
hablando la vicegobernadora de florida
janet núñez hablemos de este estado que
para muchos es estratégico rumbo a la
presidencia de eeuu daisy cuáles son los
resultados que tiene la visión ahora que
ahora estamos escuchando cómo está la
comunidad latina respecto a los
sentimientos con donald trump y con el
partido demócrata
sabemos muy bien que todos los caminos
llevan a florida y estas elecciones de
aquí a los próximos 60 70 días antes de
noviembre 3 vamos a ver a los candidatos
gastar mucho dinero y pasar mucho tiempo
que la florida porque es probablemente
muy difícil no ganar las elecciones sino
ganen el estado de la florida así que
ambos candidatos babington entienden eso
lo que hemos visto en la florida es un
cambio demográfico donde ante las
poblaciones cubanoamericanas del sur de
la florida eran fuertemente
republicanas y apoyan al presidente pero
hemos visto que en la parte central de
la florida especialmente en el área de
orlando el colo que es el corredor i-4
que es entre orlando y tampa ha llovido
muy incluso de otras poblaciones también
por ejemplo aquí en el sur de la florida
tenemos más personas de colombianas
dominicanas
de otros países suramericanos
o sea hay una una coalición de
diferentes etnicidad es entonces ya no
el psc voto seguro por el presidente no
está tan seguro como era antes así que
vamos a ver creo que más un voto más
hacia hacia las cosas que son
importantes para los latinos estamos
viendo como el presidente ha tratado a
los inmigrantes
hablando del pro de ser pro-vida cómo
separó a niños e infantes de sus madres
de sus familias
y cómo ha sido una política muy cruel de
cómo han tratado a estas personas
también hemos visto como cuando él dijo
de los 170.000 muertos por el cob y qué
bueno es lo que es entonces si vamos a
hacer pro-vida vamos a hacer pro-vida a
ver todos no solamente de algunos y en
este sentido creo que los latinos los
inmigrantes estamos viendo la actitud
del presidente qué
mucho más favoreciendo a las personas de
dinero de raza blanca de los sitios
rurales que no es donde estamos la
mayoría de nosotros así que vamos a ver
a personas a los candidatos pelear por
este voto que es muy importante muy
crucial en estas próximas elecciones y
hablando también de las iniciativas del
presidente hemos visto que el ha
enfocado su ataque en contra de los
demócratas con 'el cuco' el miedo del
socialismo sí con lo que estamos viendo
es el socialismo es lo que estamos
viendo el parte del presidente en
minimizando la importancia de la prensa
diciendo que no sepa lo muerto decide no
irse de la presidencia si no gana eso
son las cosas que hacen los dictadores
socialistas así que real socialista aquí
es el presidente de donald trump y ahí
puedo mencionar muchas otras cosas que
ha hecho inclusive eliminar a los
señores de las agencias etcétera
bien bien y las queremos escuchar daisy
y vice pero vamos ahora a aprovechar que
tenemos a diego área y amarilli cancio
primero con diego quien es el experto en
política exterior estadounidense llegó
aprovechando nuevamente que tenemos en
vídeo trump parece ser el foco de
atención lo estamos viendo ahorita es
va a hablar diego déjame regresar
contigo primero escuchamos a donald
trump quiero agradecer por todo el
trabajo hoy eeuu está feliz recibiendo a
cinco nuevos miembros a la gran familia
estadounidense ahora ustedes son
conciudadanos de esta gran nación
felicitaciones
y siguieron las reglas o decirnos las
leyes aprendieron la historia y
respetaron los valores y probaron que
son hombres y mujeres de la mayor
integridad y no es algo tan fácil y
apreciamos que están aquí con nosotros
el día de hoy ustedes se han ganado
mayor
desde cualquier lugar del mundo se llama
la ciudadanía estadounidense no hay
mayor honor ni mayor privilegio y es un
honor para mí ser su presidente muchas
gracias
en este momento quisiera reconocer a los
cinco nuevos ciudadanos que se unen a
nosotros el día de hoy
de bolivia ha sido un residente
permanente desde el 2013
con robert
en tres hermosos hijos en 2017 robert de
logros el sueño de comenzar su negocio
una empresa de construcción que ahora
tiene cinco empleados él dice que ama
este país que quiere respetar la ley
eeuu me ha ayudado y me ha dado tanto en
la vida muchas gracias robert por tu
devoción gracias por la oportunidad de
ser un ciudadano gracias buena suerte
con esa compañía pronto tendrás cientos
de empleados que me querían desde líbano
cuide ser la madre orgullosa de tres
niños habla inglés árabe y en francés y
tiene un diploma en psicología entonces
tal vez pueda entenderme ahora trabaja
como profesor en virginia y dicen me
siento muy afortunada de ser ciudadana
del mejor país del mundo un país que me
ha dado la oportunidad de en la vida
para alcanzar mi potencial y mis sueños
felicitaciones
[Música]
muchas gracias
soderling no es
es una es un gran éxito que nació en
india
que llegó a eeuu de 13 años de
desarrolladora de software ella y su
esposo tienen dos niños hermosos las
manzanas de tu vida
bueno presentaciones gran trabajo de
abusar buenos aires es de sudán y ese es
un nombre muy hermoso y ha sido un
residente permanente desde el 2012
es madre y tiene un pienso en nutrición
animal de la universidad de wyoming gran
estado
también es una veterinaria ha trabajado
como profesora sustituta para la escuela
pública desde 12 muchas gracias y
felicitaciones es un honor estar aquí
contigo gracias
han estado buscando este día desde que
llegó a estados unidos desde ghana en
esta ley habla cinco idiomas y trabaja
en el campo médico dice que la
ciudadanía estadounidense significa todo
para mí en mi vida no puede ser medido
cuantificado tengo la oportunidad de
tener oportunidad de trabajar duro y
tener éxito en la vida y saber que estoy
en un país tan seguro como eeuu eso
realmente es algo porque sé que me
apoyen y muchas gracias por esa
situación es gran trabajo felicitaciones
a todos
con los derechos y libertades que ahora
ustedes disfrutan como ciudadanos no hay
sueño más allá de su alcance porque los
estadounidenses pueden hacer cualquier
cosa hoy también han aceptado los
deberes y responsabilidades que llegan
con la ciudadanía estadounidense y con
este juramento de ustedes han entrado
un compromiso inquebrantable con nuestro
país su juramento su lealtad con el
pueblo estadounidense con la
constitución y con la manera de vida de
eeuu con la historia y la herencia de
los eeuu ahora son de ustedes para que
lo preserven y lo pasen a la próxima
generación nuestra cultura nuestros
valores ahora son suyos para que los
respeten y vivan por ellos
lo que nos han dado a nosotros y lo que
nos ha dado dios y lo que está en la ley
de derechos para esta gran nación una
familia de todos los colores credos y
religiones unidos por los lazos del amor
saludando a una gran bandera
estadounidense en presentaciones de
nuevo que dios los bendiga y que dios
bendiga nuestro gran país estados unidos
el presidente estadounidense donald
trump da la ciudadanía a personas que
según él tienen los méritos para ser
ciudadanos estadounidenses ahora
escuchamos a su hijo eric trump cuando
yo estuve en la convención hace cuatro
años nadie realmente comprendía el
cambio histórico que iba a ocurrir y
todos podemos sentir lo sabíamos que
algo estaba ocurriendo en movimiento se
estaba formando en la superficie los
hombres y las mujeres olvidados y pies
que no tenían voz en washington se
estaban preparando para levantarse
nuestro movimiento siguió el patrón de
tantos de otros que sigue que hubo antes
primero fuimos ignorados
después se rieron de nosotros después
lucharon contra nosotros y después
juntos ganamos a partir de ese momento
eeuu llegó primero eeuu comenzó a ganar
de nuevo comenzamos a ser respetados de
nuevo pero siempre existió un
contramovimiento y si son los radicales
demócratas dicen que este país es la
fuente de los problemas creen que el
único camino es borrar la historia y
acabar con el pasado
quieren destruir los monumentos de
nuestros padres
y respetar nuestra bandera quieren
quemar esta bandera que representa el
patriotismo y el sueño estadounidense
quieren y respetar el himno
arrodillándose mientras que las fuerzas
armadas arriesgan sus vidas para
protegerla no quieren el juramento o
decir que somos una nación bajo dios
quieren desfinanciar y respetar a la
policía los demócratas quieren estados
unidos donde sus opiniones son las
censuradas cuando no están alineadas con
las de ellos el presidente reagan dijo
que la libertad no está nunca a una
generación de la extinción y debe ser
que se debe luchar por ella y es una
lucha que solamente mi padre puede ganar
y mi padre se lanzó no porque necesitará
el trabajo sino porque sabía que las
personas trabajadores de este país se
estaban quedando atrás los medios se
rieron de estas personas que ignoraron
las banderas de champ y las gorras
las banderas de los llamados líderes
estaban arrodillados entre china estaban
dándole dinero eran y pensaban cómo iban
a ser recibidos por las salientes de
parís de se preocupaba más por eso de
cómo vivían las personas en pittsburgh
nosotros perdimos amigos pero eso nos
impulsa a luchar más duro él juró que
cada estadounidense en cada estado y
ciudad que iba a hacer que estados
unidos fuera grande de nuevo y después
comenzó el gran regreso estadounidense
se acabaron las regulaciones y los
impuestos llegamos a una economía a unas
alturas nunca antes vista el desempleo
llegó a su punto más bajo especialmente
para los afroamericanos para los
hispanos para las mujeres los tratos
comerciales fueron renegociados las
mujeres los derechos de millones de
estadounidenses regresaron millones de
dólares regresaron a estados unidos
nuevamente eeuu se hizo la envidia del
mundo
y con esa fortaleza llegó el
apalancamiento el presidente pidió que
los aliados pagaran su parte justa por
la defensa del mundo occidental
reconstruyó las fuerzas militares subió
los sueldos para los hombres y mujeres
en uniforme expandió el presupuesto a
700 mil millones de dólares y ya no
éramos débiles ante los ojos del enemigo
y acabamos con los mayores sonrisas del
planeta
este es el día que en eeuu
juro nunca ser tratado por el enemigo al
pacte de solimán y muertos
una y otra vez tema tras tema la
economía el muro la los recortes
fiscales los jueces de la corte suprema
las right train llevar la embajada a
jerusalén la paz de medio oriente
james están acabando las guerras
promesas hechas y
promesas por primera vez se mantuvieron
la mayoría de los políticos pasan la
mayoría de su tiempo en bici y no
cumplen con nada por ejemplo
yo vaivenes un político que ha estado en
el gobierno durante 47 años y es un
político de carrera que nunca que no
sabe nada sobre el trabajador
estadounidense o sobre los negocios del
país el motor que empuja la mayor
economía que el mundo de jamás haya
visto el mismo político que
estamos estado sujeto a la china
comunista que ha pasado años huyendo
militar y aún también
joe biden ha permitido aumentar sus
impuestos en 4 billones de dólares la
gran mayoría del país verá aumentar la
wta como aumentan sus impuestos y le
daría amnistía y salud a todos los
inmigrantes ilegales en bailén han
jurado de financiar a la policía y
acabar con su querido segunda enmienda
en mi padre por el otro lado dio los
mayores recortes de impuestos y saben
que si no tenemos fronteras no existe un
país y siempre va a apoyar a la policía
ya las fuerzas y respetar el derecho de
portar y guardar armas
todos los días en su lucha por los
hombres y mujeres olvidados del país
aquellos que representan al espíritu
estadounidense que es como nada en el
mundo
el construyó la represa hoover y bajo
martín
a marte se puede sentir en mont roig
puede ser visto en los ojos de cada niño
cuando tomen su primera respiración el
mejor país que el mundo haya conocido en
el país que derrotó el comunismo y el
fascismo y que va también a derrotar
las visiones radicales de la izquierda
radical
en la cita de reagan acaba con esta
advertencia un día podemos pasar nuestro
tiempo diciendo a nuestros niños como
era en eeuu donde los hombres y las
mujeres eran libres por presidentes en
la libertad nunca será cosa del pasado
por eso está eso es lo que representa un
voto porción es un voto por el sueño
estadounidense por el espíritu y por la
bandera de este país
por el oficial de policía que ha sido
atacado en castigado y cuyo trabajo
quieren extinguir
mi padre luchará por ustedes para todas
las religiones a todas las personas de
fe en guayas fue venid muchas libertades
quieren ser acabadas mi padre luchará
por ustedes aquellos que no tienen voz
aquellos que han sido censurados
cancelados
mi padre luchará por ustedes a nuestros
campesinos y granjeros que trabajan para
mantener nuestros platos llenos con mi
padre de luchar por ustedes a cada madre
y padre a cada veterano a nuestros de
mineros y para los trabajadores
estadounidenses
mi padre luchará por ustedes y para cada
estadounidense orgulloso que cree que el
azul el blanco el rojo
mi padre continuará luchando por ustedes
y primero quisiera hablarles
directamente a mi padre
extraño trabajar a tu lado cada día pero
me siento muy orgulloso de estar en la
línea de frente de esta lucha me siento
orgulloso de lo que haces por este país
me siento orgulloso de mostrarle a mis
hijos lo que hace su abuelo y me siento
orgulloso de
ver como nunca te detienes como sigues
adelante como sigues luchando por lo que
es correcto estás haciendo que eeuu sea
fuerte de nuevo estás haciendo que eeuu
se aseguró de nuevo estás haciendo que
el país sea orgulloso de nuevo y si
juntos con los hombres y mujeres
obligados que finalmente ya no son
olvidados estás haciendo a eeuu grande
de nuevo padre vamos por otros cuatro
años te quiero mucho que dios te bendiga
y que dios bendiga a los eeuu de américa
eric trump el tercer hijo del presidente
estadounidense donald trump un
empresario estadounidense el pues en
cuatro ejes se dividió su discurso el
primero era contra los demócratas
calificándolos de que le quieren faltar
al respeto a los símbolos como la
bandera como el himno nacional aludiendo
por ejemplo al jugador de fútbol
americano colín kaepernick quien se
hincaba durante el himno estadounidense
cuando esto lo hacía como señal de
protesta contra el racismo que
identifica el jugador de fútbol
americano el segundo eje es sobre
política exterior mencionó logros del
gobierno de donald trump como por
ejemplo el éxito de la paz en medio
oriente así lo identifica eric trump los
datos comerciales mejoras económicas
derechos de las mujeres logros en el
congreso' el tercer eje criticó
específicamente a joe biden como una
persona que ya ha pasado su mejor
momento que lleva 47 años
estadounidense por lo tanto pues no sabe
no entiende al trabajador estadounidense
o cómo hacer negocios dice que aumentará
impuestos ahí remar remarcó que su padre
donald trump ha disminuido los impuestos
y el cuarto eje habló pues de una faceta
más personal lo que muchos estaban
esperando palabras de cariño para su
padre que extraña trabajar al lado de
donald trump que le dijo específicamente
te quiero mucho algo que no se escuchaba
al menos por parte de sus hijos muy
constantemente en estas convenciones el
d se desempeña como vicepresidente
ejecutivo de desarrollo y adquisiciones
en la organización de su padre
dirigiendo las nuevas adquisiciones de
proyectos y de desarrollo por todo el
mundo y es dueño de un viñedo y de una
bodega en el estado de virginia donde
pues se le ve
constantemente ejerciendo como
empresario enlazamos nuevamente entonces
con diego área porque pues estos dos
pronunciamientos han sido muy
importantes en esta noche el primero
donald trump dando la ciudadanía a
personas que tienen méritos según él es
un tema polémico el de sí donald trump
se se le atribuye que demoniza a los
inmigrantes y que parece que está
utilizando tanto la convención de ayer
para pulir su imagen
de racismo a algunas acusaciones que
tiene en su contra y hoy pues su imagen
de que demonizar a los inmigrantes cuál
es tu opinión diego área él es el
experto en relaciones internacionales y
política exterior estadounidense
muchas gracias y yo pienso que hay un
contraste muy interesante entre entre
los dos discursos las dos acciones no el
presidente chop como tú bien lo ilustra
tratando de reconectar con con los
migrantes otorgando la ciudadanía a
estos cinco a estos cinco migrantes que
hoy se quedan sois ciudadanos hay que
recordar que todavía hay 12 millones de
inmigrantes que no gozan con estatus
legal en los eeuu lo que genera una
profunda desigualdad y los convierte en
una población supremamente vulnerable y
lo vemos con cómo han sido afectados por
el cobista aproximadamente 30% de tasa
de contagio cuando el averaje de la
población general de los estados unidos
es de alrededor de un 12%
por otro y siempre de nuevo reforzando
las campañas políticas son repeticiones
son profundización y de mensaje y en
este momento tiene que aprovechar la
plataforma del partido y la campaña
throne para seguir posicionando ese
mensaje seguirle hablando de las bases
que fueron quienes los llevaron a la
presidencia en el año 2016
de forma inesperada para el para el
status quo de los eeuu fue la base
republicana esa base dura que a la que
seguir apelando de hasta el final de
esta elección
específicamente exacerbando y
y siguiendo haciendo el contraste con la
con las diferencias históricas que tenía
este país el tema de la tenencia de
armas el tema de las libertades
religiosas el tema del aborto y la vida
el tema del racismo me parece muy
interesante y quisiera resaltar como en
tanto ayer como hoy en la convención
republicana tanto la gobernadora de iowa
tanto el joven que vino a visitó el
problema con los con los manifestantes
del partido demócrata todos hacen
mención y mantienen la narrativa
antisistema en contra de los medios de
comunicación en contra de las grandes
empresas tecnológicas incluso siendo si
estando en la administración del poder
la injerencia del poder de los estados
si éstos probablemente se va a seguir
profundizando a medida que se que se
siga la carrera electoral y seguiremos
viendo este contraste y este llamamiento
a las bases para movilizarse masivamente
el día electoral
diego precisamente nos estás
identificando que ciudadanos
estadounidenses que pueden ser vistos
como promedios son los que están
hablando a favor de donald trump
en lo que llevan estos dos días parece
ser las voces más reconocidas son las de
ellos y las de sus familiares que no
veremos a pesos pesados del partido
republicano defendiendo al mandatario
bueno hay dos cosas hay una herramienta
muy poderosa en comunicación que son los
validadores y ese es el estadounidense
promedio que le da un mensaje a sus
pares que es capaz de transmitir un
mensaje que es capaz de contar una
historia que se parece a las mayorías
pero hoy tenemos en el en el roster para
llamarlo alguna forma a dos pesos
pesados la primera vez melania throne
que pocas apariciones ha tenido y que su
última aparición en una convención fue
muy criticado por entidades familiares
sin duda pero tendremos también a otra
muy polémica aparición el día de hoy muy
criticada desde las líneas del partido
demócrata como es el secretario de
estado my pompeo que desde israel en una
gira por oriente medio para seguir
profundizando la influencia y las
relaciones de israel con el resto de la
región lo va a hacer desde allí creo que
eso va a generar mucho interés y podemos
esperar sin duda alguna que siga
reforzando el contraste ideológico que
sigue reforzando las alianzas
geoestratégicas que tiene el presidente
camps y que seguramente mantendrá en el
futuro sí y muy esperado ese discurso
desde israel pero en un lugar
desconocido no se informó donde hablará
mike pompeo regresó contigo más adelante
diego ahora vámonos con nuestra
estratega republicana marili canción
marilyn me gustaría más hablar de esta
escena que vivimos de donald trump dando
la ciudadanía a los que él considera
tienen méritos suficientes para ser
estadounidenses
te voy a pronunciar algo que ha dicho
donald trump desde el inicio de su
campaña él ha dicho que la inmigración
ilegal masiva atrae millones de
trabajadores con mano de obra barata
para competir por trabajos y
oportunidades contra los estadounidenses
más vulnerables quitándoles el sueño
americano cuál es el mensaje en general
que puede dar donald trump respecto a
sus políticas migratorias
muy sencillo el down trump es pro
migración ilegal hay muchas personas que
están aquí esperando años y años
haciendo fila tratando de traer tus
familiares y no han logrado poder
traerlos porque están cumpliendo con la
ley con las normas yo creo que es muy
importante que se entienda que este
presidente es un presidente que quiere
que las leyes se cumplan que las
personas que quieren venir aquí de forma
legal serán bienvenidas a este país
necesitamos inmigrantes los partidos
republicanos es un partido que abre los
brazos los migrantes que quieren venir
aquí a vivir el sueño americano son
personas que están huyendo de regímenes
terribles que vienen aquí a buscar lo
que todos nosotros queremos que es
seguridad y poder trabajar tener un
pequeño negocio salir adelante en este
país uno trabaja duro y puede salir
adelante porque aquí tenemos esa
libertad y eso es lo que promueve no
mucho porque si pueden venir aquí pero
vengan
siendo invitados o que vengan con un
permiso
vengan con un visto pero lo que no
podemos permitir son millones de
personas que quieran venir aquí de una
forma ilegal es muy sencillo los
inmigrantes son bienvenidos a nuestro
país pero tienen que venir de una forma
legal muy bien muchas gracias marili
cancio sigo contigo más adelante vámonos
ahora con nuestra corresponsal en
washington diana castañeda diana el
presidente de donald trump para muchos
es un experto en televisión tiene un
gran recorrido en los medios de
comunicación tiene realities que han
sido exitosos y además pues una figura
muy mediática para muchos que insisto es
un experto en televisión está logrando
que esta convención lo que hemos visto
al día de hoy ayer por ejemplo vimos lo
que conocemos en televisión como un
reportaje tenemos a mike pompeo ahí
vengo contigo escuchamos a mike pompei
tengo un gran trabajo n como el padre de
nick y el esposo de sus susan y nick
están más seguros y sus libertades más
seguras porque residente trump ha puesto
su visión en acción tal vez no haya sido
popular en cada capital exagera pero ha
funcionado el presidente entiende que no
por todo lo que queremos y deseamos para
nosotros y para nuestros hijos
asegurar la paz es el primer requisito y
de hecho la primera función
constitucional es mantener que es su
familia y la mía estemos seguros y
mantener la libertad de vivir aprender
trabajar y orar como quieran estoy aquí
para cumplir con esto es mantenerlos
seguros y nuestra libertad está intacta
este presidente ha llevado a cabo
acciones audaces en cada rincón del
mundo en china le ha quitado la cortina
a las prácticas depredadoras del partido
comunista que lo ha hecho
rendir cuentas por el virus y por la
destrucción que ha causado en eeuu en el
mundo y no se va a quedar tranquilo
hasta que se haga justicia
también ha acabado con los se ha
asegurado que los espías que están eeuu
sean enviados de nuevo a su país
y también ha acabado con las prácticas
que dañaron empleos y esos empleos ahora
están revisando el país en corea del
norte le bajó la temperatura y en contra
de todas las apuestas los llevó a la
mesa la negociación no ha habido pruebas
ni de misiles ni de armas nucleares y
los estadounidenses que estaban cautivos
allá volvieron a su país
gracias al presidente la otan están más
fuerte ucrania tiene el sistema de
defensa y podemos ahora construir
misiles para disuadir la agresión rusa
en medio oriente cuando irán
son submarino
pero no a la muerte de qasem soleimani
el nombre responsable por muerte de
miles de cristianos en el medio oriente
y también se acordarán que cuando el
presidente llegó al cargo el terrorismo
radical islámico le cortaba la cabeza a
la gente gay y controlar el territorio
del tamaño de gran bretaña hoy gracias
al liderazgo de watson el califato de
isis se acabó
abubakar al pactado y está muerto y
nuestros soldados valientes están de
regreso a casa
díaz fue el saco a eeuu de la desastrosa
acuerdo nuclear con irán y presionó a
hamás y a los ayatolás
buen presidente también llegó la
embajada de eeuu a esta ciudad de dios a
jerusalén la capital de la tierra judía
y solamente hace dos semanas y stuart
christie logró un acuerdo de paz
histórico entre israel y los emiratos
árabes unidos wireless 3 un acuerdo del
cual nuestros nietos van a leer en los
libros de historia como saltado yo vi de
primera mano a las personas desesperadas
para unirse a la libertad
como nosotros podemos seguir con estas
libertades se mantengan eligiendo a
líderes que cumplan no solo que hablen
en turquía
con las palabras de la biblia y tener fe
y terminar bien si mantenemos el curso
lo haremos que dios los bendiga y que
dios bendiga a nuestra gran nación los
estados unidos de américa
el secretario de estado mike pompeo que
rompe décadas de precedencia no usa la
voz al usar la oficina con fines
partidistas en estas convenciones él
mencionó los logros principales en
materia de política exterior del
gobierno de donald trump específicamente
señaló a china dice que el partido
comunista tiene acciones que son
devoradoras y entonces que el gobierno
de donald trump pudo hacerle frente
refiriendo por supuesto a la guerra de
comercial y los aranceles también los
identificó como los culpables de el
coronavirus la pandemia que azota a
nivel mundial
dijo que mandó espías de regreso a sus
países volvió a tocar el tema de los
inmigrantes que arregló las políticas
migratorias a favor del empleo
estadounidense identificó el asunto con
corea del norte según el secretario de
estado ha suavizado estas tensiones que
habían entre el gobierno de corea del
norte y los gobiernos anteriores
estadounidenses dijo que refiriéndose a
la otan que ahora la otan es más fuerte
y que ahora se permite para eeuu
construir misiles que hagan frente a lo
que identificó como una posible agresión
rusa también hablo del terrorismo
radical islámico ahora que está en esta
región en jerusalén desde un lugar no
revelado donde hablo mike pompeo dijo
que es un histórico el acuerdo nuclear
con irán del cual el gobierno de eeuu se
salió porque consideraban que era
injusto para los estadounidenses y
finalmente mencionó que la embajada de
eeuu ahora está en jerusalén
enfatizó los beneficios del pacto
histórico entre israel y emiratos árabes
unidos
ese fue el pronunciamiento muy esperado
de mike pompeo el secretario de estado
estadounidense quien es pues la figura
diplomática del gobierno de donald trump
y quien se encuentra en este viaje
oficial a medio oriente para presionar
por un acercamiento árabe israelí más
amplio después de que israel y emiratos
árabes unidos como el mismo identificada
llegaron a un acuerdo para normalizar
completamente las relaciones my pompeo
se dirige a esta convención nacional
republicana a pesar de que un mes antes
recordó a los empleados de la
cancillería que no se involucren
indebidamente en este proceso político
ahora estamos viendo imágenes de la
primera dama melania trump quien hablará
en cualquier momento y que lo hará así
se espera desde el rose garden
precisamente del que está supervisando
una renovación del jardín de rosas de la
casa blanca una restauración a su plano
original de 1962
remonta a la administración de kennedy
es un discurso muy esperado el de
melania trump desde este jardín de rosas
que bordea la oficina oval y el ala
oeste de la casa blanca' y que se
utiliza comúnmente como escenario para
recepciones y eventos mediáticos debido
a su proximidad a la casa blanca hace
unas semanas fue melania tromba que
ordenó que se retiraran los macizos de
flores y los árboles ornamentales
plantados por jacqueline kennedy y hubo
quejas de opositores y quejas públicas
por por ello estamos entonces viendo las
imágenes de la primera dama que lo
decíamos también al inicio de esta
emisión especial su discurso pues
buscará olvidar el de la convención
republicana de 2016 que estuvo envuelto
en controversia y críticas después de
que su misma campaña la campaña de don a
tromba admitiera que algunas partes de
su alocución habían sido tomadas
directamente del discurso de la entonces
primera dama michelle obama esto en la
convención nacional demócrata de 2008
estamos viendo llegan llegar a la
primera dama de eeuu donald trump
también por supuesto tenemos a nuestras
dos estrategas para que hablen respecto
al papel de melania trompe escuchamos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
dime varias noches y la angustia se
parece que fuera solo ayer cuando
estábamos en nuestra primera convención
donde mi esposo aceptó la nominación
republicana y después se convirtió en
nuestro presidente número 45 de eeuu
la energía y el entusiasmo por quien
debería liderar esta nación
tanto ahora como hace cuatro años sé que
hablo por mi esposo y por toda la
familia cuando digo que no hemos
olvidado a las personas increíbles que
están dispuestos a apostar por un hombre
de negocios que nunca había trabajado en
política sabemos que fueron ustedes
quienes lo eligieron para ser comandante
en jefe y sabemos que son ustedes
quienes nos van a llevar al más allá de
la línea de meta de nuevo gracias a su
gran apoyo entonces y aún seguimos
agradecidos por ese apoyo quiero
reconocer el hecho
que desde marzo nuestras vidas han
cambiado de manera drástica el enemigo
invisible 19 llegó a nuestro hermoso
país y tuvo un impacto en todos nosotros
simpatía y simpatía para todos aquellos
que han perdido un ser querido y mis
oraciones están con aquellos que están
enfermos o están sufriendo sé que muchas
personas se sienten ansiosas y muchas no
saben qué hacer quiero que sepan que no
están solos en la administración de mi
esposo no va a dejar de luchar hasta que
exista un tratamiento efectivo o una
vacuna disponible para cada uno
donald no va a descansar hasta que haya
hecho todo lo que puede para cuidar a
todos los impactados por esta terrible
pandemia
quiero extender mi gratitud a todos los
trabajadores de la salud a los
trabajadores de primera línea
profesores que han salido adelante en
estos tiempos difíciles a pesar de los
riesgos para ustedes y para sus propias
familias ustedes han puesto primero a su
país y mi esposo y yo nos sentimos
agradecidos
me he sentido conmovida por la manera
como los estadounidenses se han unido en
esta situación que puede asustar es en
tiempos como estos que podemos al cual
miraremos desde el futuro y diremos que
a través de la compasión la fortaleza la
amabilidad la determinación fuimos
capaces de restaurar la promesa de
nuestro futuro
los negocios salieron adelante y también
los voluntarios y las personas quisieron
compartir sus ideas sus recursos y su
apoyo de todo tipo con sus vecinos y con
las personas que no conocían
igualmente sí ha sido muy inspirador ver
cómo las personas de esta gran nación
pueden hacer unos por otros
especialmente cuando estamos en nuestro
momento más frágil
hablando de fortaleza y determinación
recientemente celebramos el aniversario
número 100 de la enmienda 19 y en el
arahal norte de la casa blanca mostramos
una exhibición dedicada al voto femenino
a los niños del país que enviarán obras
de arte
para este para conmemorar este tiempo
importante la historia las mujeres que
reflejaban el impacto de la voz femenina
en la historia de este país y que tan
orgullosa me sentiré de votar nuevamente
por donald trump en noviembre debemos
asegurarnos que las mujeres sean
escuchadas y que el sueño americano
continúa triunfando
y creciendo en eslovenia que estaba bajo
el comunismo siempre escuchaba de un
lugar increíble llamado américa un lugar
que defendía la libertad y la
oportunidad a medida que crecía se
convirtió en mi objetivo ir a eeuu y
seguir mi trabajo en la industria de la
moda
mis padres trabajaron duro para asegurar
que nuestra familia no solamente pudiera
vivir y prosperar en estados unidos sino
también pudieran contribuir a la nación
que le permite a la gente llegar con un
sueño y hacer que ese sueño se convierta
en realidad
quiero tomar un momento para agradecer a
mi madre a mi padre por todo lo que han
hecho por nuestra familia es por ustedes
que estoy aquí el día de hoy
[Aplausos]
y esto llegue a los estados unidos
cuando tenía 26 años working él vivía y
trabajaba en la tierra de la oportunidad
era un sueño hecho realidad pero yo
quería más quería hacer una ciudad
después de 10 años de papeleos y
paciencia entre estudié para la prueba y
en 2006 me convertí en un ciudadano
estadounidense
y destiló van de progres momento sigue
siendo los momentos de mayor orgullo en
mi vida porque con trabajo duro y
determinación pude lograr mi propio
sueño americano como una inmigrante y
una mujer independiente comprendía lo
que significa el privilegio de vivir
aquí y poder disfrutar de las libertades
y las oportunidades que tenemos
hasta es lady como primera dama he
tenido la fortuna de ver el sueño
americano volverse realidad una y otra
vez
he conocido a muchas mujeres
inspiradoras niños padres y familias que
han superado problemas incluyendo la
adicción
la falta de hogar miembros de la familia
enfermos muertos muchos abusos y muchos
retos
quería que muchos se rindieran en los
últimos tres años y medio
claramente han sido inolvidables no hay
palabras para describir lo honrada
lo humilde que me siento y también lo
afortunada de poder servir
en esta nación como su primera dama
después de muchas de las experiencias
que he tenido no sé si realmente puedo
explicar totalmente cuántas personas me
llevo a casa en el corazón cada día
desde los soldados valientes que dejan
tanto atrás para que podamos ser libres
hasta los niños de todas las
circunstancias que he conocido alrededor
del mundo
muchas gracias por inspirarme es el
mayor honor poder servirles cuando hablo
con miembros de las fuerzas militares a
pesar de los tiempos de sacrificio con
sus familias de haber experimentado la
guerra o haber sufrido una pérdida no
tienen lamentos de haber servido a este
país los mismos va para las familias y
de los trabajadores de primera línea
cuando esas personas salen y no saben si
o cuando volverán
o cuando hablo con familias
es un dolor mezclado con orgullo y eso
es algo en lo que pienso muy seguido
entonces gracias a todos aquellos que
sirven a nuestro país en las fuerzas
militares y como trabajadores de
emergencia y también gracias a las
familias que esperan por ellos ustedes
también son nuestros héroes
y me he sentido como vida por los niños
y en las familias con los cuales he
pasado tiempo en eso en hospitales en
escuelas y en otras ubicaciones
alrededor del país o niños que se están
enfrentando al dolor
[Música]
la enfermedad que acabaría incluso con
el adulto más fuerte padres que se
despiertan para saber si sus hijos aún
están vivos
ellos son un testamento a lo que pueda
ser nuestra confianza en la medicina y
en la ciencia en mi primer viaje como
primera dama al exterior mi esposo y yo
visitamos lugares de gran significado
para las tres grandes religiones isla
más el cristianismo y el judaísmo
tengo una memoria de ese viaje es una
joven que tuve el privilegio de visitar
mientras estuve en un hospital de roma
italia
allí le leí una pequeña historia y
aprendí que él y su familia habían
estado esperando un corazón durante
mucho tiempo y él tenía un pronóstico
difícil esta historia nos hizo llorar y
volamos
a bélgica para la siguiente parte del
viaje para aterrizar solo a una horas
después aprendimos que un corazón había
sido donado y que iría para ese niño si
pienso en él muchas veces junto a otros
pacientes fuertes y valientes en todo
este país
otros ejemplos inevitables de esta
fortaleza del carácter estadounidense
han aparecido en las comunidades que han
sido impactadas por los desastres
naturales los huracanes los tornados y
las inundaciones muestran el lado oscuro
de la madre naturaleza pero después
también nos muestran un lado hermoso de
la humanidad mi esposo y yo hemos
visitado muchos lugares que han sido
afectados por los desastres naturales y
nos sentimos conmovidos por la fortaleza
de las personas que han perdido todo
y la amabilidad de los vecinos y las
comunidades y la característica común en
todas estas situaciones es la
determinación inquebrantable para
ayudarnos unos a otros reconozco las
historias que acabo de contar son de
personas que han sobrevivido a
circunstancias extraordinarias pero
donald y yo también nos sentimos
inspirados por los millones de
estadounidenses que se despiertan cada
día
con un objetivo simple de proveer para
sus familias y mantenerlas seguras
ustedes son la espina dorsal de este
país ustedes son las personas que
continúan haciendo que eeuu de américa
lo que es
de harvey que tienen la increíble
responsabilidad de preparar a las
próximas generaciones para dejar todo
aún mejor de lo que encontraron
así como ustedes están luchando por sus
familias mi esposo y nuestra familia y
las personas de esta administración
estamos aquí luchando por ustedes no
importa la cantidad de titulares
negativos o mentirosos por parte de los
medios donald trump
los ojos no va a perder el foco en ese
objetivo el ama este país si él sabe
cómo hacer las cosas como han aprendido
en los últimos cinco años él no es un
político tradicional él no solamente
habla él pide acción y obtiene
resultados el futuro de nuestro país
siempre ha sido muy importante para él y
es algo que siempre he admirado de hecho
de crear un mejor futuro para las
próximas generaciones y es por eso que
lancé la iniciativa be best para
ayudarlos a alcanzar su máximo potencial
vives tiene un único objetivo enseñarle
a la juventud la importancia de su
bienestar tanto mental como físico
también incluye comprender la seguridad
online y los peligros del abuso de los
opioides y las drogas a través de vives
el cargo y yo hemos podido crear
programas a través de organizaciones que
están haciendo cosas extraordinarias en
nuestro país y alrededor del mundo hay
continental y continúo creyendo que está
creando una luz sobre estos ejemplos
positivos otros alrededor del país y del
mundo se inspirarán para hacer su parte
por nuestra próxima generación a ayudar
a los niños no es un tema político es
nuestro imperativo moral cuando pienso
en un momento esencial de vives
pienso en un viaje que hice a áfrica en
ese vasto y hermoso continente puedes
visitar los países de ghana malawi kenia
y egipto
una de esas visitas en particular tuvo
un impacto muy profundo en mí
en ghana en la costa fue la primera
parada de ese viaje a y experimenté de
primera mano a sus personas cálidas y
sus bellas tradiciones estando allí
visité que el castillo de cape coast y
aprendí más sobre un viaje cruel en la
era del intercambio de esclavos me sentí
horrorizada cuando escuchaba al guía
contándome tantas historias inhumanas y
creé una nueva perspectiva y stei de ese
momento en la historia que nunca debemos
olvidar para que podamos asegurarnos que
nunca ocurra nuevamente como todos
he pensado en el tema racial que sacude
el país es una dura realidad que no nos
sentimos orgullosos de partes de nuestra
historia y aliento a las personas para
que se enfoquen en nuestro futuro
mientras aún puedan aprender de nuestro
pasado debemos recordar que hoy todos
somos una sola comunidad
religión formada de muchas razas
religiones y etnias history nuestra
historia diversa es lo que hace que este
país sea fuerte y aún así aún tenemos
tanto por aprender unos de otros con eso
en mente quiero hacer un llamado a los
ciudadanos de este país para que puedan
tomar un momento una pausa y miren a las
cosas desde todas las perspectivas
urko a las personas para que se unan de
manera cívica para que podamos vivir
según nuestros estándares de ideales
estadounidenses y también le pido a las
personas que detengan la violencia y los
robos que se hacen en el nombre de la
justicia y nunca hagan a soluciones
basados en el color de la piel de una
persona en lugar de derribar cosas
pensemos en nuestros
errores sintámonos orgullosos de nuestra
evolución y miremos el camino hacia el
futuro todos los días recordemos que
somos una sola nación bajo dios y que
tenemos que querernos unos a otros y
apreciar nos mies por la administración
de mi esposo ha trabajado para tratar de
crear un cambio cuando se trata de temas
y problemas alrededor de la raza y la
religión en el país es el primer
presidente que sí
que ha hablado desde la asamblea general
de la onu haciendo un llamado a los
países del mundo para acabar con la
persecución política y religiosa y
honrar el derecho de cada persona de
orar como también lo escoja ha hecho
inversiones sustanciales en las
universidades históricamente negras y en
las universidades también continúa
luchando por la posibilidad de elegir el
colegio dándole a los padres la
posibilidad de que sus hijos florezcan
él sabe cómo crear
pero cambio desde el día que lo conocí
él solamente ha querido hacer que este
país sea el mejor que puede ser durante
muchos años esto lo vi frustrado y
preocupado y me siento tan orgullosa de
ver que las cosas que ha hecho en tan
poco tiempo y eeuu está en su corazón
y aunque el momento solamente podamos
ver lo peor de las personas y de los
políticos en las noticias recordemos
cómo podemos unirnos en los momentos más
difíciles
y aunque el debate continúa por los
temas raciales concentrémonos en los
avances que hemos alcanzado y trabajemos
juntos en un mejor mañana para todos
nuestra administración también ha dado
recursos históricos y generando
resultados creando conciencia alrededor
del abuso de drogas y los opioides
especialmente para los niños
muchas veces en los titulares están
llenos de chismes
yo quisiera tomar este momento para
alentar los medios a concentrarse aún
más en la crisis de drogas que enfrenta
el país esta enfermedad es una que
afecta a todos y no le importará el
estatus socioeconómico la raza o la edad
de esta adicción ha golpeado cada parte
de la sociedad y ahora mucho más que
antes tenemos programas en la medicina
para poder combatirlo solo tenemos que
poder hablar de esto de manera abierta y
ustedes los medios tienen la plataforma
para hacer que eso ocurra a la industria
de los medios y al país les pido que
todos nos comprometamos para ayudar en
la lucha en contra de la adicción a las
drogas hablando de esto aún más
especialmente mientras luchamos contra
la pandemia del cob y tenemos que
recordar
los suicidios van en aumento linas ya
que hay personas que se están
enfrentando a la soledad y a la adicción
y piensan que no tienen un lugar a donde
acudir por favor padres enseñarles a sus
hijos los profesores también los
legisladores aprueben legislaciones para
ayudar a aquellos que necesitan ayuda y
hacerlo de manera segura y sin miedo y
dando recursos a las organizaciones que
ayudan a las personas que han sido
impactadas por la adicción estigma
extremo cuando se acaba el estigma la
gente ya no tendrá vergüenza de
solicitar ayuda y sus vidas estarán más
seguras y serán salvadas si ustedes
tienen problemas con la adicción no hay
vergüenza con esta enfermedad por favor
busquen ayuda ustedes se lo merecen hoy
es en mis próximos cuatro años como
primera dama continuará construyendo su
reconstruido con be best
apoyaremos la aprobación de
legislaciones para los más vulnerables y
continuaré con el trabajo que he
comenzado con los niños así como en las
comunidades y en las naciones tribales
quiero asegurarme que los niños están
siendo protegidos y las comunidades
tengan los recursos para poder combatir
la adicción a las drogas y el abuso
infantil como mi esposo y la esta
administración continuará alentando la
educación que apoye las necesidades
individuales de los niños es vital que
los niños tengan los bloques para poder
construir su futuro y su éxito también
continuará con el trabajo de restaurar
esta casa que es un gran símbolo de
orgullo para la gente de este país creo
que este hogar icónico debe ser
preservado y cuidado para que puedan ser
disfrutados por el pueblo de este país y
también para los visitantes del mundo
durante años
me siento apasionada por esta grande y
hermosa casa por todo lo que representa
y ahora tengo un mensaje especial para
las madres de este país
y este mundo moderno avanza tan rápido y
nuestros hijos se enfrentan a retos que
parece que están cambiando cada pocos
meses justo como yo ustedes ven cómo
puede ser dañina en los medios sociales
dice que muchos de ustedes están
buscando respuestas sobre cómo hablar
con sus hijos sobre el lado peligroso de
la tecnología y las relaciones con otros
como cada padre en este país siento que
hay muchas lecciones que tenemos que
enseñarle a nuestros hijos y las
responsabilidades para las madres no
están solamente ahí para hacerlas todas
tenemos
me acuerdo que tengo soy muy afortunada
y hay días en los que busco fortaleza y
sabiduría para hacer lo mejor que pueda
por él por mi hijo
para las madres y padres en todo el
mundo
ustedes son guerreros en mi esposo
ustedes tienen un presidente que no va a
dejar de luchar por ustedes y sus
familias
veo lo duro que pelean día y noche y a
pesar de ataques sin precedentes de la
oposición y los medios él no se va a
rendir y él simplemente trabaja más duro
[Aplausos]
es un esposo que me apoya en todo lo que
hago ha construido una administración
con un número sin precedente de mujeres
en cargos de liderazgo y ha creado un
ambiente donde el pueblo estadounidense
siempre es la prioridad y él le da la
bienvenida a diferentes puntos de vista
y le gusta pensar por fuera de la caja
sé que hablo por mi esposo y por la
familia cuando digo que estamos muy
agradecidos porque le dieron la
confianza de ser nuestro presidente y
estaremos honrados de poder servir este
país por cuatro años más
[Aplausos]
ming como han escuchado no quiere
utilizar este tiempo precioso atacando
al otro lado porque como vimos la semana
pasada esto solamente sirve para dividir
aún más a la nación estoy aquí porque
necesitamos que no es que mi esposo sea
presidente y comandante en jefe por
cuatro años más
él es lo mejor para este país todos
conocemos la pacifista este es el
discurso de melania trump que se enfocó
en destaca la fortaleza de su esposo
habló del aniversario número 100 del
voto femenino y llamó a votar a las
mujeres por supuesto rescató a sus
antecedentes como inmigrante y como eeuu
señaló es un país de oportunidades
agradeció a las fuerzas militares ya los
trabajadores que atienden la emergencia
del cobi 19 y lanzó un llamado a la
unión sin importar la raza o el credo en
un claro guiño a los manifestantes del
black lives mother finalizó con con una
frase somos una sola nación bajo dios y
nuestra historia diversa
lo que hace a eeuu fuerte vamos a
concluir esta emisión especial del día
de hoy primero escuchamos a la estratega
republicana ella es marilyn cancio
cuáles son tus conclusiones esta
convención le dará votos a favor a
donald trump es normal que después de
las convenciones pues se suba la
popularidad de un candidato pero se
espera mucho de este específicamente
me encantó el discurso de nuestra
primera dama creo que tenemos una
primera dama magnífica escucharla hablar
es recordarle al pueblo que ella no
nació en este país pero ama muchísimo
este país está haciendo una labor
increíble con este programa que tiene de
pipas de ser mejor y me pareció muy
bonito la forma que habló de su esposo
de su hijo de su familia pero el amor
por nuestro país de tratar de unir al
país hablando sus experiencias como
primera dama en los primeros cuatro años
sus diferentes viajes y yo creo que
podemos terminar la convención después
de este discurso porque sí creo que ha
sido magnífico y algo muy positivo muy
bonito muy alentador hablando de temas
que nos unen a todos nosotros no creo
que nadie puede estar desacuerdo con lo
que hablo de tratar de eliminar todo lo
que tiene que ver con el tema de
adicciones de cuidar y proteger las
familias y no estaría de acuerdo con
ella muy bien muchas gracias marili
cancio y por por tu análisis y por tu
comprensión también de estos breves
espacios
es que tuvimos durante el día de hoy
vamos ahora para escuchar por último del
día de hoy a diego área el experto en
política internacional específicamente
ubicado ahí en eeuu en la capital en
washington diego te dejo pues una
pregunta si no hubiera habido pandemia a
donaldson tendría asegura la reelección
y también tus comentarios finales nada
más tenemos un minutito
seguro gracias bueno sin duda alguna la
pandemia cambio el juego por alto beni
ha encaminado sobre todo con una
economía
creciente bien encaminada y bien
comunicada la pandemia vino a generar
incertidumbre y una felicidad económica
muy profunda que pone en entredicho y el
manejo y su uso y su manejo de la crisis
ha generado también ha generado también
muchas críticas por último yo quiero
decir que el discurso de la primera dama
me parece me parece muy acertado me
parece que así debería ser la política y
ya pudo allí expresar sus diferencias
con los adversarios pero de una forma
elegante de una forma respetuosa
utilizando la simbología de estar en la
casa blanca para mandar un mensaje
también al pueblo americano resaltando
el rol de la mujer que es tan importante
pero creo que sin duda alguna así debes
de ve hacia asia hacia discursos con ese
tono debe moverse a la política en
general tratar de evitar la hiper
polarización para poder para evitar los
extremos y construir y seguir
construyendo en momentos tan duros poder
avanzar
y avanzar como sociedad diego me dicen
que tenemos un minutito más lo quiero
aprovechar contigo precisamente y es que
vamos a hablar que se viene no se habló
mucho de la pandemia no se ha hablado
mucho del coronavirus y de sus muertes
es más vimos ahí en la convención que no
estaban usando cubrebocas nadie hay
presente cómo se va a manejar este tema
es justificable que no se use este tipo
de protecciones que son evidencias
científicas y que van a ser tanto los
republicanos como los demócratas como
estrategia final rumbo a los debates
donde veremos a los dos candidatos
y
vuelvo y conectó con la conversación que
estábamos teniendo antes lo creo que la
polarización y el querer generar esos
contrastes
le hace daño tanto a la conversación
como a la sociedad en general y sin duda
alguna el manejo la forma como se ha
llevado esta crisis por parte de la
presidencia ha generado críticas y eso
se fundamenta en la inicial en la
inicial resistencia de la administración
en reconocer la importancia que tenía
esto luego rápidamente se hicieron los
avances pero más allá de eso se utiliza
un tema tan sensible y que se ha llevado
tantas vidas como también una fuerza es
una fuente de polarización y de iu para
resaltar las diferencias entre entre
entre grupos de ciudadanos de este país
entonces
desde la lógica más conservadora desde
la empresa desde desde lo privado está
el postulado de que hay que proteger la
economía que no puede no puede
simplemente pararse la economía porque
la decir el orden y la sociedad entra
una crisis muy profunda que no se puede
sostener
y por otro lado aquellos que te dicen la
vida es lo que hay que lo que hay que
proteger y que salvar entonces y cada
quien tiene su posición simplemente yo
creo que la vida tiene que pelear sobre
sobre cualquier otra perspectiva
política pero perú pero hacia ahí hay
que ir gracias diego arias él es experto
en relaciones internacionales radicados
y en eeuu gracias por supuesto a daisy
va es la estratega demócrata con quien
ya no pudimos volver a enlazar amarilli
cancio la estratega republicana ya
nuestros corresponsales diana castañeda
y mauricio cárdenas por supuesto a usted
muchas gracias también por su compañía
ya van dos noches de la convención
republicana esta mitad le va ganando a
la mitad de los demócratas ahí se las
dejo gracias por su compañía sigue con
más
[Música]